WOODMARK TESTOSTERONE GUARANTEE
THAT YOU WILL VOTE FOR THE GOP?
A STUDY FROM CLAREMONT GRADUATE
UNIVERSITY FOUND THAT INCREASED
LEVELS OF THE MAIN MALE HORMONE
CAN CAUSE DEMOCRATS TO BECOME
MORE CONSERVATIVE IN THEIR
POLITICAL AFFILIATION DURING
2012 ELECTION CYCLE, THEY
RESEARCHED 136 VOTING AGE MEN
LUCKY RESEARCHERS.
THEY FOUND A RED SHIFT AMONG
GUYS WHO WERE GIVEN TESTOSTERON
BOOSTERS COMPARED TO THOSE WHO
TOOK PLACEBOS.
NO WONDER.
BONDS WANTED TO JOIN CPAP.
WHEN DEMOCRATS RECEIVED
ADDITIONAL TESTOSTERONE THE
STRENGTH OF THE PARTY FELL BY --
AND THEY HAD WARMER FEELINGS
TOWARD REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES.
BEFORE THE TESTOSTERONE
TREATMENT WE FOUND THAT WEEKLY
AFFILIATED DEPTH THREATS AT 19%
AND IDENTIFIED STRONGLY WITH TH
PARTY PICK OUT OF WHAT I JUST
SAID THAT IT SOUNDS IMPORTANT.
THE SCIENTISTS CONCLUDE THAT
THESE [LEAP]
>> IT'S IN THE RESEARCH.
NO WONDER ELON MUSK LAST NAME I
MOST.
VOWING TO VOTE REPUBLICAN
BECAUSE THEY WERE MOSTLY KINDA
KINDEST PARTY BUT THEY BECOME
THE PARTY OF DIVISION ON HAIGHT
SO I COULD NO LONGER SUPPOSED
THEM AND WILL BOOK REPUBLICAN.
WITH THE TESTOSTERONE LOBBY HAS
ALREADY TRIED TO CATCH IT ARE
YOU SLUGGISH DURING THE DAY AND
WISH TO LIVE IN ANOTHER COUNTRY?
DO YOU HAVE STRANGE THOUGHTS
LIKE CONSIDERING VOTING DEMOCRAT
?
THIS HORMONE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
EVERY AWESOME THING THAT MANKIN
IS SEPARATE DONE AND JUMPING
INTO GENERATION OF WEEKLY
AFFILIATED --
UNLEASH YOUR INNER CONSERVATIVE.
EVER SINCE I STARTED HOUSTON
TESTOSTERONE, I CAN'T HELP --
[INDISCERNIBLE]
>> I SPENT EVERY DAY OF MY LIFE
READING ABOUT THE GREEN NEW DEAL
.
NOW I SPEND MOST MY TIME READIN
ABOUT THE CONSTITUTION PICKED
BEST OF ALL I'M NO LONGER A
VIRGIN.
EXPECTS ONE MORE SIDE EFFECT SO
IF YOU'RE --
AND THE OLD RED, WHITE, AND BLUE
, THEN TIE --
TRY TESTOSTERONE.
WELL DONE ACTING.
SO, DAVE, MUCH LIKE THIS STUDY
YOU ALSO FOLLOWED 136 MEN.
WHY NOT.
I HAVEN'T SEEN YOU IN A YEAR.
THIS MAKES SENSE.
>> WELL, I HAD NO IDEA THAT THE
SAID SOMETHING TO DO WITH
TESTOSTERONE.
I THOUGHT IT WAS JUST THE SOY
THAT WAS KEEPING THEM.
LIBERAL SPEAKERS WERE ALWAYS
THERE.
I CAN TELL YOU AS SOMEONE THAT
WAS RIGHT ON THE WIRE, SOMEONE
THAT WAS PROGRESSIVE, THE WHOLE
THING, I CAN TELL YOU I'VE NEVE
BEEN MORE THEN I AM SINCE I'VE
BEEN HERE AT THIS VERY MOMENT A
WHEN I SAW YOU EARLIER IN THE
MAIL ROOM, YOU WERE TELLING ME.
>> WE WERE LOOKING AT OUR FACES
WHEN WE WERE TALKING.
I COULD FEEL YOUR BREATH.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO DO THIS.
I TOLD YOU THAT THIS IS GOING T
BE THE NUMBER ONE SHOW IN
LATE-NIGHT.
WE ARE THE MOST SUCCESSFUL SHOW
EVER THAT SAYS THINGS BETTER
THAT ARE COMPLETELY TWISTED AND
WRONG.
>> I HATE TO CORRECT YOU.
YOU KEEP SAYING WE.
YES, I DO.
I GET SO MAD BECAUSE IT CAN
NEVER BE BECAUSE IT'S THE RIGHT
DECISION IT MAKES SENSE.
BECAUSE WE READ AND WE THINK AN
WE DON'T LIKE BIG TAXES.
NO, WE GET GASSED UP AND GO WOKE
.
[LAUGHTER]
>> OH, MY GOSH.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT THE OTHER SID
IS GOING TO DO HERE, DON'T YOU.
THEY'RE GOING TO SAY, SEE, THE
REPUBLICANS AND CONSERVATIVES
ARE ALL AGGRESSIVE WITH THAT
TESTOSTERONE AND THEY'RE ALL
JUST MEAN AND THEN THERE'S GOIN
TO BE THIS ANTI- MALE THING, AS
IF THERE WASN'T ALREADY.
AND A FEW MORE THINGS.
HOW DARE YOU.
VERY FONDEST NEVER TESTED
POSITIVE FOR ANYTHING.
NEVER ONCE.
HE ONLY TESTED POSITIVE FOR MY
LOVE.
>> WITH EFFORT.
YOU ACTUALLY HAVE MORE
TESTOSTERONE THAN I DO.
WHEN I FIRST MET YOU, I BEGAN T
UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS COMING OUT
OF YOUR MOUTH.
IT WAS LIKE A TRUCK DRIVER.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I PROBABLY GET A LOT OF
TESTOSTERONE LIKE THE VOICE AND
THE PERSONALITY.
ANYTHING ELSE OTHER THAN
COMMENTATING ON MY HORMONES.
TO YOU BY THIS QUICK.
>> I DON'T BUY ANYTHING LIKE
THAT IS A SMALL NUMBER PICK IT
COULD MAKE SENSE BECAUSE
HORMONES DO AFFECT YOU SOMETIMES
.
LIKE ANYONE WHO IS A CHECK WILL
BE LIKE THE NIMH CHECK.
YOU ARE.
I CAN'T STRESS THAT ENOUGH.
THE DOCTORS WERE CONFUSED FOR A
WHILE.
WHY DO I LAUGH LEFT LIKE BEAVIS
AND BUTTHEAD.
WHY DO PEOPLE ON THE INTERNET --
LIKE THIS IS THE ONE THAT I HAV
CHOSEN.
ALRIGHT.
WE'VE GOT TO GO UP.
GO UP.
IS CANCELING WOKE MS. A BRI